Google came from my mom saying I was
crazy like cuckoo cuz I was like a goofy
kid
my grandparents speak Spanish so they
would say I was at cuckoo yeah what
service cuckoo am I here with tasty why
don't make some enchiladas better this
food that I grew up eating because I'm a
mom on my favorite dishes so yeah if you
want your salsa to be spicy you can up
the number serrano peppers if you like
it more mild
I recommend easily maybe like one or
just like half of serrano pepper you can
also remove the seeds I personally like
spicy so I put a serrano peppers in them
make a hot the reason why we boil the
tomatoes onions garlic and the serrano
peppers is because we want to maintain
the green color if we were roast
ingredients we'd get more of like a
brownish sausage I think it's just
really crucial to go try Mexican to it
if you haven't tried it before because
it expands beyond like tacos tacos are
good but there's a lot more really good
dishes in the culture it's a lot rather
chilaquiles don't does shortly there's
good food everywhere all cultures it's
good to know where the good spots are
out in your city you go somewhere else
quite radically spots in our cities
there's definitely worth taking extra
time to fry the tortillas a crispy
tortilla is more likely to hold its
shape while baking and the enchiladas
will be less mushy
after you finished final tortillas
you'll dip them in the remaining salsa
this will make them easier to roll
instead they don't dry out while baking
we're using rotisserie chicken here but
this recipe is also good if you have any
kind of leftover chicken you're trying
to get rid of it we're arranging your
thieves in the baking dish make sure to
arrange them seam side down this way
they'll continue to hold this shape and
fill in during baking I go crazy with
the cheese cheese and the katakana like
it's just fire I think food like really
connects people music and food are both
like art
paparazzo crema mexicana onion and
cilantro this is how balanced off the
spice from the salsa verde
you know these enchiladas Google
approved why I'm sent
[Music]
mm-hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]